foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsey
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life your
relationships your mental health your
work and your money I'm John deloney
joined here by my good friend George
Campbell and we're taking your calls on
life and money give us a buzz at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go right to the phones let's
go to Frank and Philadelphia where he
was born and raised what's up Frank
oh yes how we doing
I'm doing pretty good pretty good good
man what's up how can we help
uh yes so uh I'm about I'm about 90 000
in a school loan debt uh I did undergrad
and I also did well I'm also currently
doing graduate now I'm I'm about
finished with uh with my graduate school
what are you studying man
I'm studying I'm studying my Master's in
business management
uh now uh and my undergraduate was in
was in media studies and production
what do you want to do Frank after grad
school
uh I wanted to open up my own
photography company but uh but I'm
learning now as I get older it's not
really lucrative so
it's an expensive lesson to learn yeah
it's a 90 000 lesson okay what are you
doing now for work
you working full-time uh
uh yes yes I'm looking full-time I work
as um I work with with with individuals
with intellectual disabilities
um
do you like that word
uh it's it's okay uh it's it's okay
definitely not something I would I see
myself doing long term I mean I love
helping people but that's not something
I see myself doing why let me ask you
this um and know this like in counseling
the the why are you you never asked that
question but I am asking that question
now okay why aren't you working in
business
why aren't you using that degree that
you've paid every drop of Blood Sweat
and soul you've got for why aren't you
leaning into how to run a business how
business Works how business doesn't work
the ups and downs what's keeping you out
of that
uh could I have it uh yeah graduated yet
uh who cares who cares have you looked
at the job LinkedIn man go talk to a
bunch of photographers most of them
never even went to college they don't
have a bachelor's degree yeah yeah and
they're running very successful
businesses well what what's your income
right now
uh my income is about 45 000 a year okay
what other debt do you have other than
the student loans
uh I have a thousand dollars
credit card that and I also have a a
seven thousand dollar uh car loan that
okay and that's it so you've got close
to 100 Grand in Consumer Debt
yes are you single
uh yes I'm single okay and are you
renting right now
oh I actually own my property you do own
it so you got a mortgage as well
no not uh just be bills
so it's paid for
yes oh okay what's it worth
I think it's about uh I think it's about
60 000 I think it's about over sixty
thousand the house is worth 60.
yeah about yes wow and is this in the
Philadelphia area is it a mobile home or
is it a single family
a single family a little home
okay
well
one piece of this equation is getting
your income up because staring at a pile
of ninety thousand dollars in debt when
you make 45 I can understand how you
feel overwhelmed
yeah
and are you making payments on the
student loans or are they still deferred
because you're in school
uh yes they're still deferred but I'm
still in school okay but this is going
to be a rude awakening when these
payments kick back up
yes yes yeah I know I know I'm trying to
repair before it actually happens uh I'm
excited to graduate in January into six
months while studies graduate in
September is six months after September
I will be passing through alone so I
want to make sure I'm prepared I'm in
the right position so I can pay them off
I love that well it's going to take
getting your income up have you already
paid for the rest of the semesters
you said you're in it through January
yes
yes okay so it's paid for there's no
more student loan debt you could get
into
no okay
man I there's two things you can do with
money you can spend less of it or make
more of it
and here's the deal you one of the
cornerstones to getting well one of the
cornerstones to help changing your
mental illness one of the cornerstones
of our healing from mental illness when
the cornerstones are getting out of debt
is owning reality
here's where I'm at here's a hole I've
got right and so and then deciding I'm
willing to do whatever it takes to to
get out
so working with people with special
needs I've done that for years it's
exhausting and tiring work right it's
hard you picked a lot of you and what
George and I are going to tell you to do
is either
keep doing that job and then as soon as
you're done grab a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich that you've made at home
and as you head to your next job that
you're going to do until 10 or 11 at
night
and you're gonna get up next morning and
do it again so that you're making 80 000
over the course of a year or 75 or 9 or
you know 78 80 85 000 a year or you
gotta find another job where you're
working in business
nearer towards what you want to do for
the rest of your years do this Frank ask
Frank where Frank wants to be five years
from now and begin to reverse engineer
that now do you want to work for a
business you work for a company do you
want to own your own place and if so you
got to learn how business Works start
looking for jobs that are going to get
you in the door there and learn how
business Works you've got an MBA uh
you're gonna know all about business but
you're not going to know how business
runs and works and feels and keeps you
up at night and all that until you
actually get in there and do it
um let me ask you this
what's holding you back
there's something there's something that
you just won't put the gas pedal all the
way to the floor what is it
uh mainly because I don't really know
how to budget money I don't I don't know
uh how how to really lose money uh I
don't really know how money Works uh
that's why I watched a lot of Dave
Ramsey uh shows because I'm trying to
learn how how to like how to budget my
money and how to be effective with my
money instead of just we can help you
with that part Frank I'm gonna gift you
one year of every dollar that's our
budgeting tool the premium version as
well as one year of Financial Peace
University that's going to give you the
money education they never taught you in
school but that's only one piece of the
equation the other piece is you and what
you're doing to increase that income my
goal for you is to become debt free in
two years but what that's going to take
is you making 90k a year and paying down
45 a year do you see the math on that
yeah hustling hustling hustling and by
the way this isn't the rest of your life
you're going to go at a pace for the
next two years that you can't sustain
for the rest of your life that's not
what we're proposing
but we're our we are proposing that dude
you have dug yourself a hole and there's
a lion in the bottom of that pit and you
got to run as fast as you can over the
next 24 or 36 months are you in
I'm in I love it okay go watch those
first few lessons of Financial Peace
University you're going to learn how to
budget you're going to learn about the
debt snowball method to get out of this
pile and you're going to call us back
when you're debt free that's all we ask
in exchange for these gifts hang on the
line Jen is going to pick up we'll gift
that to you this is the Ramsay show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm John deloney joined by George
Campbell and we're taking your calls
give us a shout we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by George
Campbell and we're taking your calls on
life money mental health marriage
whatever you got going on we're here for
you let's go to Carrie in Rising Sun man
what a cool name for pretty rock and
roll what's up Carrie
Hi how are you guys outstanding what's
up
cool this is so exciting okay I promise
it's more exciting for us I promise oh
um so a colleague that I work with a
nurse her name is Erica she recommended
that I read The Total Money Makeover and
since I read it I've been kind of hooked
and
um just propelling forward to our future
of being debt free and I've been sharing
with my husband what I've been reading
and we've been applying it so in the
last six weeks we've paid off roughly 13
Grand in credit card debt all right whoa
um I have another six grand in three
weeks we plan to pay off leaving me with
originally I thought it was two lines
but we actually have three loans so
after we pay off this last credit card
I'll have a horse trailer loan a Jeep
loan and then just paying off our roof
loan George has several uh for our roof
to Elite George has several horse
trailer loans so yes if I had a nickel
yeah
yeah
um so we have a 12
and 2 18 to two years we plan on moving
south and you know taking our horses and
opening up a little a small horse ranch
my question is every time I
pay off my credit card I call the
company and I have them close the
account I cancel it and then I shred it
but each time I just feel a little pit
of nausea and I wonder am I really doing
the smarter thing because I was always
raised and unfortunately I have raised
my daughters as well to think that you
need a good credit score to be able to
buy a house to be able to rent and to
buy a car and so I am kind of back
peddling with my daughters and I'm
trying to say hey I screwed up here but
let's look at this hold on hold on hey
I'm gonna let George solve the the your
mom of the Year already the process let
me tell you this
uh and this is a common misconception
this is literally
destroying the country
okay
yes this idea that once I say something
even if I'm passionate about it I
Proclaim I'm gonna do this when I get to
office I'm doing this and this and this
and then I get there
and I get behind the curtain and I
realize what I said I was about to do is
going to make everything worse or I tell
my son you want to be a man it looks
like this and this and this and then I
go to counseling for the first time and
I realize oh I'm the problem and then I
sit down let me I'm telling you all I
tell you this the greatest gift you can
give your daughters
is the gift of saying hey I really
believed in this this is how I was
taught and then I learned something new
and here's the magic phrase I was wrong
period all wisdom all wisdom starts with
the words I was wrong and I learned
something new I I on my show the other
day I was telling somebody
um I give a nutrition advice which I
shouldn't have been doing and one of the
smartest men on the planet Dr Lane
Norton called me on my phone he goes hey
man you were wrong you gave wrong and
you know what I was really grateful
because then I could go make it right
does that make sense so the greatest
gift you give you're not selling your
kids out or kind of jerking around no
you are teaching them what wisdom looks
like which is to learn something new
practice it believe it strongly Go full
force and then when you learn something
new do something different good for you
your mom of the year as George said good
for you okay
thanks okay so Carrie I felt the same
way when I was getting out of debt
because I was I thought the same I was
like well I gotta rent cars I gotta I
rent apartments how am I going to live
my life and then I realized the whole
thing is a scam because I went to my
apartment with no credit score and they
were like oh yeah that's no big deal you
tend to pay the first month's deposit
I'm like oh okay cool and then I went to
rent a car and they were like yeah cool
we'll just put a 300 hold on the debit
card and I was like oh okay cool and
then I went to get a mortgage and
there's a thing called manual
underwriting with a no score loan they
went hey do you have a 12 month rental
history and proof that you've paid other
bills on time and they were like okay
cool here's a mortgage and so it just
made me go oh my gosh we've been scammed
all along you don't need a credit score
to live your life
and I've got I George I don't know about
you carrying on about you when I had
credit cards and I would cancel them
I would feel like I was
um cutting off one of my exit strategies
like I had 50 different exit strategies
in case it all went down and every time
I got rid of a credit card I felt like I
was shutting one big door and like my
body felt a little bit like okay now we
only have 49 Avenues to escape if it all
goes down in the 47 and then 42 and then
right and I think it's it's completely
reframing debt is the is debt is the
prison you're locked in it's not the
solution to get out
foreign
I'm going to give you and your daughter
some homework this is a fun uh thing you
guys can do together go listen to
episode 7 of the fine print I did a
whole episode called the dirty truth
behind your credit score I literally
call random apartments and homes across
the country and I ask them can I rent
without a credit score and I talked to
the mortgage lenders and I say hey what
does it look like for me to go through
this process of manual underwriting and
they explain it in full and so I think
it will give you a lot of peace and
confidence for this plan going forward
and let me tell you what's going to
happen you're going to pay off that debt
in 18 months and once you close all
accounts six to 12 months later after
that you're going to have an
indeterminal indeterminable credit score
but in that six to 12 months guess what
you're doing saving up a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses saving up the down payment on
the house and so you got plenty of
things to do until that credit score
Falls away and then you're going to move
into that next phase of your life with
such peace and confidence because you're
not going to be drowning in payments
anymore you're going to have money in
the bank to cover emergencies so know
that you're doing the right things
okay yeah I appreciate that because I'm
I'm always sharing what I'm reading with
my husband my husband always looked at
me with such faith and trust and he's
just like are we doing the right thing
and I said according to Mr Ramsey uh
um well it's according to it's according
to Dave but it's also according to
millions and millions and millions of
people yeah the proof isn't anybody
anything yeah they owe nobody anything
so you are on the right path
um George I think it's important to add
one thing
um and that lead us into this article we
got here man
they might have to say no to some things
as they would start their business they
want it to look like this and have all
this cool like handy like awesome
artwork done in the wood and all this
they may have to phase that in over time
because they're going to pay at the
speed of cash right and so there is
going to be some oh she can look like
this right now but it's gonna look like
that in two years that's gonna be part
of it right because we're going slow and
we're doing it right that's always worth
it in the end yeah I mean swimming
Upstream there's there's downsides it's
harder to swim upstream yeah it's a
slightly harder to live in a world where
credit is put on this pedestal but what
you also find is that you have less
anxiety and you're worried less about
that next paycheck and that counts for a
whole lot more than me playing this game
so I can have a quote-unquote easy
convenient life that's right
um all right so George we got this
article that uh Austin's handed us says
over the past seven days Americans are
searching for credit card debt one and a
half times more than student debt and
you and I have both seen the numbers
inflation's at an all-time high people
are struggling financially yet uh
holiday spending was the highest it's
ever been in the history of the planet
and well think about it we're more
strapped than ever and so where do we
turn to credit other than credit cards
right and what does that mean oh the
interest rates are now jacked up to
record highs to you know where it's 25
interest and you thought you were going
to pay it off next month but then life
happened and inflation and the emergency
and all of a sudden you're paying 25
interest and it's ballooning and so now
we're seeing U.S searches for how to pay
off credit card debt reached a five-year
high within the past month and to my
friends who are complaining about how
the Washington just keeps racking up
debt and spending their your money look
at your own credit card statements look
at your own bank notes look at your own
car notes
George like this is
let me ask you this question because
this feels Madness to me is this credit
card debt that is just I mean it's it is
insane it's insane one and a half times
student debt so at least student debt is
paying for an education that's going to
take you this way you this is paying for
a meal you already ate it's really hard
to justify that credit card spending is
this is this spending to prop up
Lifestyles to keep them going as they
were or is this because eggs I I have to
eat I think it's both and I think a lot
of it is emotional and some people are
really struggling where they have to
turn to their credit cards because they
don't feel like they have a solution and
some people are enjoying some retail
therapy John just they I'm Gonna Keep My
Lifestyle up no matter how little how
far my dollar is or isn't good
stop spending on credit cards
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
George Campbell taking your calls on
life and money give us a shout let's go
to Diamond in Jackson Mississippi what's
up Diamond
Hi how are you outstanding how are you
I'm all right excellent what's up
okay if I have a question
um I was recently on YouTube and I saw
David Dave Ramsey's um growth stock
mutual fund tutorial for video
and um I have a question I was trying to
open it was set in the counter or a
mutual fund up and I want to know should
I open up the account through a bank or
like do an online brokerage
I just did this last week so I could I I
can tell you what I did but George can
walk you through the the the
traps and pitfalls of certain Avenues
and then I'll tell you exactly what I
did so where where is this coming from
that you're wanting to kind of invest
outside of retirement
um
actually like I said I know he's
tax-free I was looking at the video and
he said
um it grows tax-free
well that's for so if you're investing
in retirement there's something called a
Roth if you have a Roth 401k or outside
of your employer you might have a Roth
IRA that keyword there is Roth and what
that means is you're just using after
tax dollars to invest that will then
grow tax-free and you can take the
distributions from that tax free so
that's what he was talking about so
that's not a mutual fund thing that's
the type of account the mutual funds sit
in
right okay so I can go to any local bank
or so and set that up or well you could
there's a lot of uh you know there's the
big the big three online that you've
probably heard of is Schwab Fidelity
Vanguard those are trusted Online ways
to do it but the question behind it is
why are you doing this right now are you
in a financial spot where you've already
maxed out retirement you're out of debt
completely you have a fully funded
emergency fund well I'm yeah I'm I'm not
in any day I'm 23 years old and I just
want to go ahead and get started awesome
do you have money in savings
do I have any money in savings yes yes I
do I do diamond you're crushing you are
amazing okay so you have no debt you've
got a pile of money in the bank is it
enough to cover three to six months of
your expenses yes and then what are you
doing for work right now
um I'm actually a registered sleep
technology
we need help
so badly kid okay so do you have any
retirement options through your employer
um I guess I think I have a 401k set up
I think they take money out of my um
check every pay period okay so you've
got some homework to do figure out what
type of account that is and figure out
how much you're contributing if you're
following our baby steps you have you're
at baby step four where you're out of
debt you have a fully funded emergency
fund and now it's time to invest 15 of
your income in retirement so what is
your income gross salary
gross salary
um I'd say maybe like 45
000 a year okay so we're going to take
15 of 45 000 and then every month you
should be investing that so that's going
to be let's see here if I'm if my math
is correct that's
67.50 a year and so divide that each
month you're going to be investing a few
hundred bucks into that account and so
if you just Mark your contributions for
15 into that 401k you are doing all you
need to do
you don't need to go to a local bank
because here's what's going to happen
you could open a Roth IRA but that's
only if you don't have a Roth option
through your employer do they have a
match have you heard about something
like that
now that I'm not for sure okay ask your
HR team and say hey do you guys have a
401k match if they do start there let's
say it's four percent you are going to
invest up to four percent and get that
match that's a 100 return on that money
because you put in four percent and they
match it with four percent does that
make sense okay right right and then
beyond that if there is no Roth option
with your employer you can go open up a
Roth IRA and fully fund that for the
year that's going to be 6 500. now based
on your income you wouldn't quite get to
that if you're investing 15 percent
because that the total you'd be
investing today is going to be 67.50 a
year but that would put you on the path
and so I don't want you to feel like you
have to get overwhelmed by setting up
your own mutual fund account and
brokerage accounts and all of this
that's for later on once you've maxed
out all of your retirement options and
so George just to recap the two things
she needs to do out of the gate is to
sit down with her HR rep at work and say
do you all have a Roth 401k option and
do you all have a match yeah we'll start
there right absolutely and then if they
don't have a Roth but they do have a
match she's going to take up to the
match and then open a Roth on the side
there yes and then once if and when your
income goes up and you max out the Roth
IRA you've got the match you then we can
move on to traditional which would be
your normal workplace you know
retirement plan but until then and until
you're in baby step seven where you have
a paid for house and you're in a
different place financially that's when
you start to go outside of retirement
and so one thing that John and I do is
we work with a financial Pro and
investing Pro to walk with us create a
holistic strategy for to help us build
wealth and you can find one of those in
the Jackson area at ramseysolutions.com
click on Ramsay recommends and get in
touch with a smartvester pro that's
actually I was going to say I so I
opened one the other day and that's what
I did and I consider myself I'm not the
smartest guy in the room in any room I
walk into but I'm not dumb and I still
don't understand all this stuff I sit by
Dave Ramsey every day I still don't
fully grasp it so I call Smart Vista Pro
and said here's what I want to do and we
talk through goals and where do we want
to be and how we're going to get there
and said great I'll take care of it for
you and here's the links and here's to
this and I've we've already talked
through and I have a relationship with
him so I know he knows what I like and
what I don't like and all that but I I
did not get online and go through it all
and learn how to I call my smart
investor Pro and that it does cost money
and it's worth it for me that's huge
well uh Diamond I'm going to send you
Dave's best-selling book baby steps
millionaires because that will kind of
get you excited and also give you the
right information when it comes to
investing because good news for you it's
a lot simpler than than most people
would tell you out there and so you get
started on YouTube which is great way
way ahead of the game Diamond just just
if you just keep staying out of debt and
you got money in the bank and you're
investing something you're already so
far ahead of most Americans I wish the
bar was higher than that diamond to be
honest but that's it you are so far
ahead so far ahead hey about this time
of year we get flooded with calls
everyone's looking for a fresh start
with their money or everybody is
tripping out because every indicator
every news pundit is going it's all
coming down and every politician's
throwing grenades but
it's been a tough couple years and the
prediction is there's going to be some
rough rough going ahead
if that's you you cannot wish for things
to change and expect it to happen you
can't just sit there at the TV and get
angry and you can't sit there and just
Doom scroll and get mad and get raged
out you can do that and you're gonna
you're gonna die younger but it's not
gonna change your financial position
you've got to do some different things
with your money you
have to do some different things with
your money and have a plan and we can
teach you that plan in Financial Peace
University this is the course that will
help you rethink how you manage your
money and you'll learn step by step how
to pay off debt and build wealth nearly
10 million people have taken FPU
followed this plan and changed their
lives it works don't try to reinvent it
don't try to get too smart don't think
that some fly-by-night newscaster
suddenly has it all figured out or some
internet sensation already
it works just follow the plan is it
painful yep uncomfortable yep does it
work yep every time when you
intentionally follow this plan with
focused intensity this year will be
different you'll have more peace less
anxiety less frazzled relationships and
more peace in your finances all across
the board so start Financial Peace
University right now at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramsesolutions.com
FPU and John I want to mention a lot of
people have they're like oh yeah I went
through that 10 years ago it's time to
go through it again number one it's
changed about a dozen times John and I
are now in it I mean how did I have no
clue how that's it's gotten more like
better looking let's be honest that's
true but on top of that there's like
nine hours of content in this and just
like a good movie you go back and watch
it like oh yeah I forgot about it I
didn't realize that oh and so there's
deep Dives on investing and insurance
and the chances are you're in a
different place financially than you
were years years ago so go through this
again I go through it about once a year
just to give me that pep I need the
information I need to get through that
year and get ahead with money and George
you and I aren't robots every month it's
like I just want to buy the I just want
to watch yeah man it's good just to have
the princess go back and to go back and
go back remind yourself why you're doing
this stuff that's right
FPU go to Ramsey solutions.com FPU this
is the Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're a new listener you're brand
new to this group of wacky people if
you're new to the cult
if you're new to Ramsay and doing things
at Ramsey Way and deciding to swim
upstream and change your life and you
want a deeper dive into the Ramsey Baby
Steps you're watching these things on
YouTube you're seeing the tick tock and
you're like what is this we got you go
to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button okay this isn't some kind
of move to like get you to buy every
it's not it man we're trying to help out
we understand that what we are telling
people to do is so counter-cultural
Washington doesn't do it your parents
didn't do it your friends don't do it no
influencer on the internets does it we
get it we get it so we want to help out
we want you to become one of the
millions and millions of people that's
changed your life so go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button and we'll help you figure
out the best next step for your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you are today everybody's everybody's
financial position is different okay go
to ramsesolutions.com and click on get
started let's go to Greg and Marion
what's up Gregory
good how are you good man what's
happening
um here the question that I had um I
have a twenty thousand dollar emergency
fund
but what I did is we needed to remodel
the basement and you know we turned it
into a living area and I depleted my
regular savings account and I'm paying
an extra thousand dollars a month on my
mortgage
do I need to stop paying as much on my
mortgage and rebuild like my regular
savings account or just keep throwing it
at the principal of the mortgage yes you
are on a pause paying extra on that
mortgage until we have that emergency
fund back to where it was let me make
sure that you no no no no no no no you
have an emergency fund and then you have
a savings account savings account what's
the savings account for
if I needed to if we wanted to do
something we did it out of that instead
of using the emergency fund or anything
like that we just
you know save that money and then we
wanted to re because I had that basement
money for about three years and finally
found someone to do it so it was
basically my sinking fund you you and
you've got leftover money in the sinking
fund for what home repairs and
renovations
yes do you anticipate more home repairs
and renovations
um no I don't okay then continue on as
long as you haven't touched that
emergency fund then you're good to
continue on and baby step six and throw
an extra on that mortgage so Greg I in a
real world application I've got an
emergency fund and I also have a truck
that's got 200 000 miles on it so my
wife and I have created a sinking fund
which we just started another savings
account line in our checking account and
I'm just putting money into that every
month
until it's the price of a car and so if
that's what you're doing that's cool but
that money is directed it's not just
like this bucket that we're just
dropping money in every once in a while
right let's put a thousand bucks here or
50 bucks here or whatever because that
that that money is not working for you
it's just kind of sitting around if it's
intentionally being pulled over for a
purchase to redo the basement to get a
new roof to get a new air conditioner
whatever that is
um that's fantastic just make sure every
one of those dollars has a name on it
does that make sense
yeah if you just got that extra money in
that savings account why not throw it at
the mortgage
okay I didn't think about that
there's one option George Burns saying
that I was having you know extra stuff
so I would rather say that mortgage
start balance start to go down that's
more exciting than sitting in a savings
account now if you know you have
something like John mentioned you know
the car is going to need to get upgraded
none of these are emergencies and so I
love the original phrase of I needed we
needed to renovate the basement it's a
want and you did it the right
ways waited for some yeah I did agree it
had the money that's awesome but those
are dangerous words whenever anyone says
I well we needed to I was forced we got
the call the other day I was we were
forced to take out the loan no no one
forced you that's not how that works you
voluntarily signed because you felt like
you had no option to go into debt that's
right so all right let's go to down the
street to Justin in canoxville what's up
Justin
hey guys it's it's exciting to talk to
y'all um my question is I've just gotten
um gotten on the I guess Dave Ramsey
plan just started listening um welcome
to the gang man
yeah
um and I I've ordered the The Total
Money Makeover it's on its way but
here's my question I'm 41. I'm a window
cleaner and I have nothing safe for
retirement and I'm just getting
I have a really hard time
um
not putting money into the market
because I know the market is down and a
lot of people are scared to put money in
the market but I'm not and I'm looking
at this as a sale and it's like time to
buy and
um and I have nothing to say for
retirement and I'm worried about
retirement because I can I can't
continue to keep doing window cleaning
until I'm 65 7. how much do you owe
Brothers
um well I can bet
uh I have 133 on my mortgage and 24 on
my cars and made 14 in credit cards and
that the thing is is I make enough money
that I can and we quit going out to eat
we've cut back I cut all my credit cards
up you know I'm cutting back on
everything so we're paying extra on
everything
but I also have this extra 15 that I can
start throwing into the retirement and
that's where I'm I'm stuck I'll let
George dig into it off top of my head
you're not gonna get 28 return in the
market no matter how on sale it is
oh and so the 28 you're paying out one
way you're trying to earn back at
the market rate which is 10 or 11 or 12
percent
see what I'm saying
yeah yeah but everybody's saying like
the market is down like everybody around
you is broke brother and listen if if if
Dave came to me Dave has a lot of cars
he's got this one Corvette I'm not a
Corvette guy I like trucks more than
court but he's got his this Corvette
that's really old and it's incredible
let's say it's worth a hundred grand I
don't know what it's worth it's probably
worth way more than that and he came to
me and said John I'm going to give you
the deal of a lifetime I'm gonna give
this to you for fifty thousand dollars
that's the deal of a lifetime it is on
super sale and I don't have fifty
thousand dollars to buy it with
both of those things can be true you are
correct I am putting more money in in uh
retirement savings this year because the
market is on sale
and I think it's going to go a little
bit lower and I'm going to keep buying
I'm with you
you don't have the money to do that
because you owe thirty eight thousand
dollars in depreciating assets and
credit cards what's your income Jace
Justin
um roughly 95 to 100. okay
so you've got if on paper I'm seeing 38
000 in Consumer Debt
yeah so if you got real intense Focus
you didn't invest a dime into the market
and this year you said I'm getting out
of debt completely could you do it by
the end of the year
uh probably how much money do you have
in the bank in liquid cash
I'm just a thousand we've just gotten
started okay now you said I love
investing in the market but you also
said I've got nothing saving retirement
so those are two confusing sentences
have you been investing outside of
retirement or you love the idea of doing
it
no I love the idea of doing it because I
I've gone all these years of not
investing and it's like now I see but
why now the Market's been because down
in previous years
yeah I mean you've had it's just I guess
watching these tick tocks where
everybody's you know talking about you
know the Market's down it's a good time
to buy you know what's not cool on Tick
Tock Justin there's someone saying hey
guys don't invest in the stock market
just start paying off your debt from
smallest to largest if I posted that on
Tick Tock today I would get about four
views and about a thousand comments of
people saying this guy's trash you need
to invest in the market and so it's all
get rich quick over there man
so turn off that input of social media
and let's turn up the fire on this debt
thing and say hey how much money would I
have to invest if I had no payments in
the world and I had a huge emergency
fund and I could breathe easy sleep
better at night and now I can start
really investing
and so one year from now you'll be there
investing in the market but right now we
have a priority of getting rid of this
debt and having money in the bank I also
I also am going to send you
um Ken Coleman's get clear assessment
it's very calm people to wake up in
their 40s and 50s and realize oh I can't
do this manual labor job in indefinitely
at some point this comes to an end I
think you're wise to start thinking what
what might that look like so hang on the
line here we're going to send you a copy
of the get clear settlement assessment
you can start asking yourself and your
family the question when we're out of
debt and I can do anything what would
that look like hey this is another hour
in the books we'll be right back on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host John deloney
I'm joined here by my good friend George
Campbell and we are taking your calls on
just about everything life money your
marriage your work whatever's going on
in your life our promises will tell you
the truth and we will sit next to you
and figure out what the next right thing
to do is give us a shout triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go out to Mike in beautiful San Diego
California what's up Mike how we doing
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
got it man what's up
so
um I'm at a point in my life where I
just I don't know what to do anymore and
I'm just really stressed out and
depressed and
I'm just I don't see the light at the
end of the tunnel anymore
um tell me about it man whatever I have
a construction business and it does
okay I mean I it does enough to pay the
bills
um
but and just I'm I don't even feel
motivated to grow it
um and
I'm just lost at what I want to do
where did where does the loss come from
man
because it what you're describing is
describing work you're describing you
know this you go you got a wife you got
kids
uh I have a girlfriend
um and we have one kid together okay I
just I went through a divorce a few
years ago okay and that was it God
messed me up mentally and financially
yeah
um was that where it started this idea
that
no matter what you do this is just kind
of kind of be the way this is
well it's kind of or did you pick that
up when you're a kid where'd that come
from man somebody gave you that story
that crappy things happen this is the
way this is and maybe you can go to a
couple of ball games and a couple of
concerts and your kid will be a good
soccer star in elementary school and
that's kind of the kind of the joy you
get who told you that man
yeah I'm not sure I'm just
oh I don't know
I just I'm really lost that's why I'm
trying to find
what my purpose is basically
so
so what do you want to do man
like if you could snap your fingers
right now what would you want to do
well I mean I love what I do in
business-wise like work
I love the construction business
um what do you love about them what I
love about it
I love building creating
um just everything about it do you like
working with customers do you like
planning and sitting with Architects or
do you like getting a crew of guys
together and going to solve a problem
and or do you like picking up the shovel
and just getting after yourself what do
you like about it
uh more like the managing side of
getting things together and
um
just
so uh labor side I mean I'm doing all
the labor right now but I feel I'm more
good at
putting everything together and getting
everything going okay what about your
what about your kids tell me about your
kid
yeah he's uh two years old yeah um
what's his name
is
he fun is he a mess he's all over the
place
oh yeah
he's really active
active is what exhausted fathers say so
they can remind themselves I still love
you I still love you I still love you
he's very active well done man so Mike
outside of your career and obviously
you've got you know your personal life
at home if you could snap your fingers a
year from now what do you think would
transform your life to where you wake up
and you're excited you know what's
keeping you up at night right now that
we can help with
okay
well
is it money or do you have money
problems
are you not happy with your relationship
well that's another I think that's my
biggest stress right now is the money's
bad because I'm in debt with friends and
family uh how much dead are you
um close to twenty thousand twenty
thousand and that's credit card debt and
personal loans
no no credit card or personal mostly to
friends and family why are you borrowing
money from friends and family dude
I got
well my business slowed down for a while
and I was just trying to think and just
trying to make anything what's your
income
um I'm a good month um like
five thousand okay and is your
girlfriend working are you guys
splitting bills how is this working
no my girlfriend she's a stay-at-home
mom at this moment okay so you're the
Sole Provider right now
yeah you got a mortgage
no no Margaret I'm renting how much is
your rent
1800.
that's a lot of rent
for your income yeah
yeah could you guys uh downsize could
you move I don't know in San Diego huh
yeah well I I tried looking at something
cheaper but everything's just
it's okay the other option is we got to
get this income up if we're going to
choose to live in San Diego
and so that becomes the next piece of
the puzzle you are you're running this
business
yeah yeah but you're also are you the
sole employee or do you have people
working for you
no I'm just a sole employee okay
so to scale how do we get this thing to
where you're making a hundred grand
well I I've been applying
um with construction companies as
project manager just
um and
I get emails saying that my application
and resume is getting a lot of attention
but I have not got one interview and I
I've applied to over 30 places I think
yeah so dude let that tell you a story
that you want to be a project manager at
a construction company you know how to
do that and 30 different companies have
said
we don't think you're quite there yet
awesome
go to the next rung right below that and
go in there
as a head of projects or ahead of
something or ahead of the construction
whatever whatever part of construction
you're really good at pouring concrete
doing landscape whatever you're good at
and get your foot in the door
you're you're absorbing every rejection
as
a statement about Mike's worth
not just somebody saying no I don't
think that's the right job for you or I
got somebody else in line for this or
everybody in California is trying to
find work and so we've got you like
at some point it because like you've got
some skills I'm thinking of you right
now me and George can't do what you do
like if we can't just run our mouths on
the radio I don't like we're in a mess
you could build a thing you can fix a
thing
does that make sense
yeah I want to see a couple of things
I want you to call betterhelp.com today
and betterhelp.com deloney and it's
going to give you a discount I want you
to go talk to a counselor okay I think
you're struggling with depression
thinking to call somebody the second
thing is we're gonna send you Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment and
proximity principle teach you to get
close to some of these guys and I want
you to read it and I'm gonna send you
FPU Financial Peace University but you
and your girlfriend have to go through
these classes stop playing house get
married start settling into this thing
and dude the light will come on if you
will look for it my brother we got you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more births
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five Hey
listen please uh it's a huge help it's a
help to us let's be honest it's helped
us but more importantly
when you subscribe and hit the Subscribe
button when you share when you like the
videos
um when you put in your five star
reviews it changes the algorithms and it
actually puts the life-changing advice
and wisdom in other people's feeds and
more people's feeds and so it's a way to
spread life change it didn't cost you a
penny but it's a way to help other
people uh your neighbors that you might
not even know now you'll never meet by
simply just subscribing hitting the like
button and the five star reviews so
thank you so much for those those of
y'all who have done that please continue
to hit the Subscribe button and share
with a friend all right today's question
of the day let's get to it it comes from
Rick in New Mexico he says we're in our
early 30s make 120 000 a year and we're
financially stable we want to buy a
house but with high prices and interest
our mortgage would be roughly 2 200 a
month we could afford the payments but
that's less we are able to save my
parents own several rentals are
financially stable and want to buy us a
house so we would just pay them rent to
1400 a month instead of us buying a
house
they said once we pay it off with no
interest they will put my name on the
house but the problem is my father can
be controlling and historically after
doing something nice he has been known
to throw it back in my face down the
road if he doesn't get his way or if we
do something he doesn't agree with
should we take my parents help or do it
on our own Rick you know this
the question you and your wife need to
ask yourself is what's the price of your
marriage and what's the price of your
soul
and what's the price of that
Thanksgiving dinner when your dad looks
across the table and says why didn't you
do this and you say well Dad I was and
he goes I I bought you a house
what's that all worth what's that worth
because the numbers you've laid out for
me it's not worth that
it is not worth that you make too much
money you're doing too well
um for you to subject to yourself
to somebody else bullying you around
just because
um there's some the you know there's
some money attached to it I'm not doing
the strings attached deal and he he's
already painting the picture of what his
life is going to be like if he does this
deal and so I think you you just need to
say hey thanks so much for the offer
we're gonna go our own way and buy our
own house uh but we appreciate you guys
and you guys make plenty of money make
120 000 a year 2200 sounds like a very
reasonable mortgage payment and uh if
you feel like it's too high or for some
reason we're not getting all the details
here you can do something called waiting
and you keep saving until you have more
down payment to lower that mortgage
payment so do it when you are ready but
don't be bullied into it don't be
pressured into it and because that is
the worst thing you can do financially
and let me say this uh Rick and
everybody listening it's often that I
hear situations like this where Mom and
Dad want to help but there's a there's
these subtle strings or really
significant strings and all that
attached to it
I'm going to give you this but you got
to do this and if you ever do that I'm
man I just I don't want that life right
um and then we turn around and feel
pressured on the advice side yo why
aren't y'all buying a house y'all gotta
buy a house I'll just rent and just
waste of money just throwing money away
throwing it away throwing it away and so
if some if you're not going to take the
deal
because you don't trust the character of
the people involved in the deal right a
gift won't be a gift a gift is just
another way to put Hooks and string into
you
don't also fall prey to their advice and
wisdom about how dumb you are with your
money you and your wife
sit down and say what kind of Life do we
want to create for ourselves and can we
create that life and what do we got to
do to make that thing happen it might
mean like George said it's going to take
two years before we buy a house cool we
don't want it to we can afford a 22 a
month payment we don't want that we
don't ever want to payment more than
17.50 whatever cool if that's the other
side rock and roll we're gonna rent a
little bit longer then and save up a
little bit more we're going to take a
few more shifts or whatever that looks
like but don't take wisdom from people
that are not trustworthy and the other
danger of this is you guys pay 1400 a
month for 10 years and all of a sudden
he decides you know what I'm actually
going to use this as a rental property
because we need the money in retirement
and all of a sudden you've been putting
money into this thing that you don't
actually own right and so that's super
risky I would not take this deal or a
little Junior decides he's going to play
soccer instead of baseball and my boys
are playing baseball I'm taking whatever
you don't know baseball family you don't
trust this guy yeah no deal no deal no
deal I keep renting man your your
marriage and solar worth it let's go to
Jason in Columbia
what's up Jason
hey how you guys doing pleasure to talk
to you guys partying dude you too what's
up
um so I had two questions well I guess
it was a two-part question but uh so my
wife and I have a vehicle right now that
is a 2020 and um we owe about 11 000 on
it and we wanted to get rid of it to
eliminate a payment
um I just started the FPU about a week
ago so I um I'm trying to get everything
in order
um so but the problem that I'm running
into is if we sell our vehicle to free
up a payment that means that uh for what
I would like to do which is get a truck
or an SUV because with that I would be
able to do some side jobs with
woodworking but I would get a vehicle
that has super high mileage and it
almost doesn't make sense to do it so
I'm not sure what I should do in that
situation what kind of woodworking
uh just building projects uh building
furniture for just uh individuals
nothing to sell the companies or
anything like that so just be side work
how often would you do this work
as often as I could I would spend nice
and weekends on if I could it's kind of
a hobby of mine something that I really
wanted to do so I it doesn't really feel
like work so I could just focus on it as
much free time as I had well here's what
I'm asking I see you driving around my
neighborhood all the time
pickup trucks with Like Home Depot
stamped on them or something or U-Haul
stamped on them and it says 19 one day
rental
um and is that ideal no dude that's the
worst it's the worst but it's also not a
truck payment it's also not a trap where
you're gonna buy a truck with super high
miles it's gonna fall apart on you and
or right now trucks are dude I'm trying
to buy a truck myself they're so
expensive the used ones with 200 000
miles are are expensive
um right how much debt do you have I'm
gonna float it dude
right uh so I'm about 50 000 in debt on
credit cards and loans no no uh no
student loans okay what could you sell
the car for
uh probably around 20 21 and you owe a
level 11 on it okay so you'd have 10K
left over to get something
right and so that becomes our goal and
we get creative and you could I mean if
it's truly for hobbies you can get the
dumpiest oldest pickup truck out there
if you just need to haul some wood
right right but I also have my wife and
a two-year-old and I have which is kind
of my last concern but I would like you
know I have a hundred pound dog that is
a PTSD dog for my life and I would like
to be able to take her with us on some
trips so that's kind of one reason why I
wanted could you get a minivan an old
minivan
sure if it made sense if them if it
wasn't like 170 180 000 miles that's
that's where I run into the problem was
if I if I do get rid of a car with such
those miles that's still under warranty
with no problems and sell it to get a
clunker I don't know if that's a smart
decision or not here's what not the
smart decision is you got no business
going on vacation for the next two years
brother
yeah I'm not going on vacation no or
that's what I'm saying like the idea is
we are locking this sucker down for two
years because we're in a hole gotcha
right
um it's you're trying to keep your
lifestyle consistent and these things
that you want to do and you want to have
fun like dude I get that you want to do
these things and at the same time pay
off fifty thousand dollars debt and have
a side hustle and
you're you're doing everything all the
same time and I don't think you fully
absorbed the amount of sacrifice that
the next two years of your life is going
to be to get 50 Grand paid off what's
your household income
about a hundred thousand okay so we
could get rid of this debt in about a
year with some side hustles
well I'm not like I say I'm new to this
but from what I figured out I thought it
was going to take about 24 months but I
I don't know maybe that was with outside
hustles as well so I mean this is we're
covering our four walls food utilities
housing Transportation every other
dollar we're going to try to allocate
towards that debt outside of our bills
we have to pay but we're not eating out
we're not going on vacation like John
said and so the question is how do I
come up with four grand I can throw with
this debt every single month and I want
to Uber great I mean I want to I want to
do woodworking awesome this isn't the
season for that
um the investment in that is going to
cost me 10 grand in a truck plus some
tools plus some I'm gonna start ubering
I'm gonna start mowing yards down the
street I'm gonna do I'm gonna keep that
that dream alive down the road but for
the next two years I gotta I got the
house is on fire and I gotta put the
fire out so I'm gonna do other work that
I don't want to do but I'm going to
scratch and clog get the sucker done man
you knock it out in one year dude that's
Game Changer now we can get a truck and
have some Hobbies you get a real yeah a
real truck man it's not going to fall
apart on you your family on trips would
be incredible triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show I'm John
deloney joined by George Campbell taking
your calls on money and life whatever's
going on in your world we're here to
walk alongside you let's go to Jasmine
in the NYC what's up Jasmine how we
doing
hi guys thank you for taking my call of
course what's up
um so I have a bit of a situation here I
am
I just started the I just finished
actually The Total Money Makeover book
and I'm in baby step two
um but I have a total of fifteen
thousand dollars in credit card debt
um so it's not much but when you think
of my age and kind of what I'm what how
much I think I really shouldn't be in
the situation how old are you um
um
20.
how did you rack up 15 grand in credit
card debt
I got credit cards and I did not know
how to spend correctly do you have a
bunch of cool stuff
uh yeah like well I think I I
was in a situation where my parents got
divorced and all that stuff and I ended
up being very very independent and I
think that way to cope with a lot of my
problems was to shop ah okay so dude
listen you're the first one to ever do
that Jasmine yeah it's wild Jasmine
listen I I talk to a lot of people a lot
on my show on this show and coaching all
over the country very few people who are
twice three times your age have the
level of insight you just displayed
the idea that hey when I am stressed
when I'm trying to figure out why my
parents broke up why my dad chose them
over me like when when you can say okay
this happens in my body and then I just
start shopping if you can link those two
together which you've done you are so
far ahead of the game because now you
know okay my body feels like this when
it does that I'm gonna create some
alternative plans so that I don't hurt
future Jasmine
does that make sense yeah I just want I
want to give you some encouragement you
are way ahead of the game now he's got
to figure out how to clean this mess up
and get on the road right so continue on
Jasmine what's the question so so I
currently just transfer schools
um to a much cheaper school because I
was paying way too much and I have
student loans I'm going into the school
now going to my junior year with no
student loans
um and I'm going to continue on
um with my next year with no student
loans as well God willing
um but I still have to pay off my
student loans that are for my old school
that's 12 000.
um I've been listening to a lot of you
guys called fashion and all that and you
guys always say like don't wait for the
government pay off your student loan and
my student loans are unable to be
touched at the moment until this until
due
um quote unquote waiting for the
government to make a decision I don't
want to gain more interest on everything
so I kind of just don't know really what
to do in terms of the order of things if
I should be tackling my credit card debt
or my student loans like I really just
kind of don't know what to do so are the
student loans broken up or is it one
giant twelve thousand dollar loan one
giant one twelve well it's broken up
unstopped Subs but yeah and total is
twelve thousand dollars but you make
individual payments on separate loans
um the provider that I have gives me an
option to either do all or one by one
okay so it sounds like they are separate
loans and so what I would do is just
list air every single individual balance
out smallest to largest and ignore the
interest rate and you said you can't pay
on them
it's it's telling me that I don't have
to until June I don't have to because
they want to get the ability to yes you
can and put your credit cards in there
as well
okay so just basically
my loans in inside of my whole snowball
yes wherever the credit cards fall in
there so if you have it sounds like
you've got multiple credit cards
yes okay yeah just list them all out
they'll be co-mingled in there in the
debt snowball but if you list them out
from smallest to largest and tackle each
individual balance you will feel the
progress versus staring at a mountain of
twelve thousand on a mountain of fifteen
thousand because the smallest balance is
probably a few hundred bucks maybe a
thousand bucks
yeah and now we go okay I could pay off
a thousand bucks and then you are the
next biggest one's two thousand but I
freed up that payment so I can roll that
payment plus the margin I was throwing
at it into the next one and that is how
the debt snowball has gotten so many
people to debt freedom and don't be
afraid to
like be as cheesy or as creative as you
want to be
um I was oh man I was in my late 30s
maybe it's mid 30s I don't remember it
was I was too old to be doing what I was
doing my wife and I were paying
everything off and we just created one
of those like construction paper chains
that you tear off every time you hit a
milestone you pay off a credit card or
you pay off you know you move that
number from 20 000 to 19 000 to 18 000
and we hung it in our bedroom just so I
have to see it every day so get creative
and just begin to knock these credit
cards out and the student loans out one
after the other after the other after
the other after the other what's your
income Jasmine okay
um I think 50k awesome 50k doing what
I'm a manager at a restaurant okay yes
I'm very I'm very blessed you can
decisions you can
knock this out in a year
right
I I hope so yes no no Jasmine you could
you could have your 21st birthday and oh
nobody anything
okay imagine that just just imagine that
for a second
yes I definitely do and then on the day
after 20 the night of your 21st birthday
your boss says hey you got to come into
work now it's my 21st birthday I took
off six months ago and he's like I don't
care what you did you're coming to work
and you can smile and be like no I'm not
because you will be free right
yes thank you awesome have you watched
the FPU videos
I've been deciding if I want to do that
or not we decided before we got you
we're going to send you uh Financial
Peace University
um because we're to welcome you to Our
Gang uh we're gonna send it to you
here's the deal you got to watch them
all and if you're really cool you can
bring a couple friends with you and
start spreading this message with them
too but we'll send you um and we're
gonna go ahead and send you every dollar
app as well as a part of this package
and you can begin to uh
um learn to manage your money as you as
you as you get better and better at
budgeting and going through all of the
lessons so hang on the line here and
Jenna will hook you up with FPU awesome
all right let's go to Stephanie in Mesa
what's up Stephanie how we doing
hey I'm doing good thank you for asking
of course I have I've been listening to
you guys for years and years I've gone
to college and taken the courses where
they show your videos and I do your
budget I have my thousand dollar
emergency fund I even went to your
conference and volunteered thinking that
would help me get out of this rut of
thinking it's not you know possible for
me but I keep think having like doubts
like I don't take it the step after the
thousand dollar emergency fund to do
anything else
um my husband's on board he said yeah
like you start saving his receipts and
all that stuff so we could do a budget
and then ice it's me I keep stopping and
giving myself excuses like I don't know
what I want to do in college after I'm
done with college I have two more
classes left before I graduate with my
bachelor's but who told you okay
Stephanie who told you that what you
want and what you need doesn't matter
I I don't know you do
you've been keeping it was your job to
make sure the adults in your life didn't
get like that Mom didn't get mad or dad
didn't get raged out wouldn't it
that is true it's always been your job
to make sure everybody else is doing
their thing and you have no Gap no space
for you to do what you know is right
what you know will give you peace what
you know will
you don't even know how to feel that and
when you go to a seminar you go to the
classes you get all jazzed up and you go
home like I'm gonna do this
and your body says this is uncomfortable
and you head off again
this the info you don't need any more
information
what you got to do is start believing
the Stephanie's needs and wants and
values matter
and here's what I want you to do okay I
want you to take your husband out for uh
breakfast one Saturday morning okay and
tell them we're gonna talk we're gonna
plan
and I want you to tell them this
knucklehead on the radio told me to
write down the things that I need that
would make my body feel safe
that would make me feel loved in this
relationship and I apologize I should
have told you some of these a long time
ago I didn't but we're starting over
from today
here's what I need
here's what I feel when
are you still in with me you still love
me and I almost guarantee you your
husband's gonna look at you and go oh
thank God I'm 100 in
and then you can get on the path to
Freedom only when you believe you're
worth crossing the Finish Line are you
going to even take that first step
you're worth it Stephanie you're worth
it we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show hey George
um hey John
oh
it sounded like an old Nickelodeon show
uh I forgot what it's called but like
you're way too old to have watched
Nickelodeon no I was I watched
Nickelodeon when it was OG dude wow I
grew up on that stuff
um
so our friends uh our friend Jill over
in SEO sent this note over the other day
um
over the last two years Monday
was the highest search for depression
over any other day in the U.S
wow and I wonder if
um
well I just keep I keep going here help
questions help with depression and
anxiety it's currently at an all-time
high in the U.S insomnia spikes in
January is currently at an all-time high
Oregon has the highest search interest
of all U.S states marriage counseling
near me reached an all-time high in
January 2023 bullet journal and diary
spikes in January in the U.S sleep
tracking is a top Trend related to
Bullet Journal at all-time high in 2023.
here's the deal
George i i i the words I I hear across
the country when I'm traveling is I'm I
feel it
we've created a world that our bodies
cannot exist in our bodies were not
designed to be constantly chained all
these different corporations who we owe
money to our bodies weren't designed to
be married to people that we didn't
really like or didn't know how to
communicate with to know how to talk to
our bodies weren't designed to sit there
and just be inundated with how we don't
look right we don't we don't make enough
money we don't drive the right thing
like we're not enough we're not enough
our bodies weren't designed to have
other people raise our kids all the time
and then tell us what's wrong with our
kids and here's why your kids doing this
and it
we just create a world for ourselves our
bodies can't live in and so I'm I'm it
makes my heart
happy to see that come January people
said enough I'm gonna go see a marriage
counselor I'm gonna go get the help for
with my anxiety and my depression that I
need
um I just want everyone out there
um
yeah things look tough and things look
like tougher right if you look down like
the country owes a bunch of money and
we've got a recession and all the stuff
all I get I get it what you can't do in
the comfort of your own couch is solve
that
you can't do anything about it and
there's for most of us when we say I
can't do anything about it it makes us
tighten our grip
and the key to anxiety the key to some
of these challenges is to loosen your
grip and for most of us we can't just do
that on our own you can't just will
yourself to do that
um and so calling somebody not just
Googling the answer but calling somebody
to get some help with it you can listen
to the Dr John deloney show my show
um and we also have an article called
how to deal with anxiety Linked In the
show notes
um for today's show that you can check
out just as a primer here's a good place
to start I want to encourage everybody
um if you're waking up every Monday
morning and you're thinking I don't I
can't do this again I can't do this
again call somebody don't Google it call
somebody call a friend and say I'm not
all right call um a counselor call
better help call somebody because I'm
not okay I need to talk to somebody tell
your wife for the first time
I'm really scared tell your husband For
the First Time The Way We Live scared me
but
um
just know you're not you're not alone
and I'm proud of you for everybody for
getting the help that they need and uh
don't give up on yourself yeah it feels
like we are and the the Silver Lining
here is where our normalizing people
seeking help that's right and they're
going I don't have to just repress this
like my parents generation did I can
deal with this I want to grow I want to
get healthy for the sake of my family my
finances all the things that matter to
me my health and so there's some good
news in this even though these searches
that are an all-time terrible it makes
people want it I also want to say this
and this is going to sound um weird
because I wrote this article how to deal
with anxiety I wrote a book about
anxiety I just turned in a draft for
another book on Mental Health stuff
I think for many of us we don't need any
more information
we need to call somebody a real person
we need connection we need a person to
sit across from us
um or to come over to the house or we go
to their house or we go grab something
to eat and we just say hey I'm not all
right here's what I'm struggling with
and good like I got two phds in this I
know the answers
the answers don't help as much as
sitting down with somebody and saying
I'm not all right I mean there's a lot
of science about that there's a lot of
Neurology about that and psychology
about that the way our bodies work but
um most of us don't need to Google yet
another article most of us need to sit
down and say
my name is John I'm not okay right so
um had the courage to go do that and I'm
proud of you all who have done that
those who are reaching out um good for
you keep doing it and if you do want uh
some information before you call
somebody check out this article how to
deal with anxiety all right let's run to
let's see here let's go to Adam and
Cincinnati what's up Adam
uh yeah
my question is I was recently fired from
a job kind of went into panic mode um
decided that
I'm going to pull from my 401k
and pay off my credit card debt and then
use the monthly
you know payments that I'm making to
those credit card debts to roll over
into a car loan and then use the
remainder of the 401K to pay down the
car to try to get out from underneath
that
um what made you feel like that was your
only option
um we
we have a fairly large house mortgage
um I make majority of the money in this
for the income for the house
um we had enough to maybe make it a
month and a half and I didn't know when
I was going to go back to work
are you working now or
um I have a job that should start Monday
so everything should return to normal as
far as you know the inflow of money
good what's what will be your income at
that point household
um our household income's right about
135 to 140.
all right how much debt do you now have
total
um so I've got a
I'd say we probably got eight in credit
cards and
probably 20 in a car
and what about the 401K loan
or did you just withdraw money
that 401k was I was very little into it
I only had I completely emptied that one
how much was in there
it was 20 I think 26 in there and I
ended up with like 14 is what it was
after taxes and penalties
so what'd you do with that money have
you already blown through that
no it's that I haven't actually got it
yet but my my plan is is once I get it
is this reverse you stop and call and
cancel it
I don't think so I think I would do
everything I can say I screwed up I got
fired I freaked out I need to cancel
this I do not want this please take it
please do not send this money
do whatever you can
okay this is a a a a fear response
a bear showed up at your cave an actual
real bear scares you to death and you
ran as fast as you could and like a like
a Wiley Coyote cartoon you just bammed
your head into a rock in the cave
okay this wasn't my this wasn't my only
retirement no I I know I know I know I'm
not saying it's your only thing we're
not all that I'm just saying
you don't need it my brother you took a
50 hit on this money and you don't need
the money you didn't need it you have a
great income you start another job on
Monday things got really scary you
panicked it happens to all of us now you
know in the future hey I need an
emergency fund but with your salary you
can pay off this debt in short order man
is it 28 total now in debt between the
credit cards and the car loan or is
there other debt
uh well I have a home Home Mortgage too
okay so we're going to ignore the
mortgage for now we're going to focus on
this Consumer Debt let's pay off this
credit card first and how quickly could
you pay that off making 140. how quickly
could you pay off eight grand going
scorched Earth throwing everything you
can at it
um
probably six months I don't know six
months okay we're gonna hook you up with
every dollar to get a plan for this
money you're making 140. are you taking
home eight nine ten Grand a month
uh yeah between me and my wife yeah
probably okay so if we started looking
at our expenses going outside of just
covering our bills putting food on the
table we're not eating out we're not
going on vacation we're not investing
you could pay this these credit cards
off within two months you got to get
serious though dude and you're like ah
watch you got to get real real serious
man
we can't want this more than you do hang
on the line we're going to send you
every dollar premium start making a plan
for your money you've got the income you
don't have to do stupid anymore you're
working hard for it now let's do
something good with it which is pay off
this debt get an emergency fund in place
and start Building Wealth the right way
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's up America we're live from the
headquarters of Ramsey Solutions
broadcasting from the ponds moving in
storage Studio it's the Ramsay show
where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your money your
relationships your marriage your kids
and your life I'm John deloney joined
here by George Campbell and we're taking
your calls just about everything the
call is free and the advice is worth
about that much but we'll give it our
best shot triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to Marie
in Fargo what's up Marie how we doing
good hey uh talking directly into your
phone
yes can you hear me
it's a little bit wobbly there
keep going we'll see if we'll give it a
shot yes what's your question okay so
I'm a fourth generation in our family
business my boyfriend and I have been
together for four and a half years my
dad wants me to get a prenup neither my
boyfriend or I want to but my brother
did recently get divorced and he did
have one
okay so I uh usually my thoughts on
prenups I'm not a fan of them
um it's it's kind of like it's planning
the end of something you're going into
it
when you've got something like a family
business here's what your a prenup can
protect you from less from your husband
your future husband and more from your
future husbands
cousin's sister's brother's roommate
or your husband heaven forbid gets sick
and passes away or gets in a wreck and
some sister or some cousin sues you guys
for your does that make sense it just
separates it all
um okay that's where a prenup can be
very useful it's less about I don't
trust him or I wouldn't be marrying him
it's more about if he something happens
to him which is why we have insurance
that's why we have Wills because
something will happen to all of us
um the heaven forbid something does
happen to him it protects your business
it takes protects your stake in the
business it protects the whole thing
from anybody coming out of the woodwork
to try to take a piece of it
okay so what's your net worth I didn't
even know that was possible yes it is
me personally
not
not that young but
um the business does around
6 million a year
that's a lot of dollars and so you would
be inheriting the business or some
portion I wouldn't inherit
Ed by myself in but yeah
yeah and so what I would do is take a
job I would start working there if
that's what you wanted to do and take it
oh no I haven't for the last decade okay
do you have enough money to buy in
uh currently I have a sliver of the pie
what is that because this on an extreme
a tiny little bit of
what's your buy-in going to be
I
apparently you only have three percent
of the money it's going to take to buy
the business or you're slowly buying it
piece by piece over time of the business
currently uh okay okay and your
boyfriend what is his financial
situation
um right now he is laid off because he's
a seasonal worker but when he does work
he makes more than I do
okay
I mean we we don't advise against
prenups in situations where there is an
inordinate amount of wealth uh that
you're coming into with this very
lucrative jewelry business so it is
something that you may want to look into
and it sounds like you guys are doing it
approaching with the right Spirit of
you're going hey I'm not doing this
because I'm nervous about marrying this
guy I'm doing it to protect us from
crazy down the line and that's that's
the way you want to think about it
and
neither of us want to get one but my
parents do and I'm just here here's
here's what I recommend said like I'm
not getting one
and that's how I feel as well but I I
just I don't know what to do
um I would sit down this is going to be
worth
um
500 or a thousand bucks to do this
um because of what what's at stake here
um I would sit down with an attorney and
your local community and tell them what
your dad has told you tell them what you
all want to do tell them what tell them
what I told you that this is less about
him and more worried about something
down the road your attorney an attorney
May advise you well he won't be an owner
you will and he would have part of your
estate like so there may be all kinds of
different ways involved here okay that
may be able to avoid a prenup I think
you have to get past the idea that a
prenup is y'all planning for your
divorce or you're planning for your
husband to screw you over that's not
what that's not we're talking about here
okay
um
one red flag for me is your husband
already planting his feet in the ground
against your dad
I'm not doing that I'm that attitude
it's before you even walk down the aisle
makes me that's a red flag for me as
someone who's just talked to a million
different uh a million different couples
sure that tells me he's more invested in
his ego and his pride than in
what's the best way I can honor my wife
what's the best way I can keep her and
this business safe and the best way we
can be connected and unified as a family
and I have to look in the mirror and say
no I got some crazy cousins or I've got
some crazy what like you know what I
mean like he's got to be able to do that
and say okay this actually protects you
in the case I get hit by a bus
okay see what I'm saying I never thought
of it from that point of view so it's
but it's it's it's a much
I get what your dad's trying to protect
his business and he's trying to love his
daughter the best he can I don't fault
him for a second I also don't fault him
for being overly cautious and you having
to say hey that's too cautious I don't
call I don't I don't um uh I don't have
any heartburn about you and your husband
saying do we really are not interested
in signing a prenup we're going into
this thing together
um I get that too that's why I would get
a third party who has no stake in any of
the family stuff or the drama and it's
just gonna give you wisdom particular to
the business to your situation your
state and local laws all that kind of
stuff so that's where I would go but
think bigger and again I'm not for
prenups I don't like him at all I I
don't like him at all but there is a
time and a place for him it's a good
word and uh with this situation he is
your boyfriend and so unless we are
really like we're about to get married
this is not a thing we have to deal with
right now I mean we don't even know if
he's going to propose what this looks
like down the line but it's good to at
least get some information from the
lawyer going hey what does this look
like on paper in a worst case scenario
what would actually happen and that will
give you some peace and confidence
moving forward with it or not moving
forward with it that's right uh hey
here's a fact about Ramsey Solutions I'm
super proud of we've never laid off
anyone
we've let people go we've never laid
anybody off
for the past 30 years we've been doing
what we preach we run a cash-based
business which means we budget for
everything that includes salaries and
compensation for our team members you
deserve the right to work for someone
you can trust someone who won't cut you
loose because of their poor planning
while other people are firing we are
hiring we have several several open
roles Marketing sales technology we want
people like you to come join our show
check out all the open roles at
ramseysolutions.com careers
ramseysolutions.com careers
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell hosting with Dr John
deloney this hour and uh John I got a
video I'd like to play for you you know
like when the substitute teacher shows
up and it's like let's watch a video I
kind of feel like the cool teacher
because of that I feel like this has
become one of your favorite things is to
say John you live in a bubble and here's
what's happening I need to look at a
screen every 30 minutes or else I spin
out of control and so this is part of
that so the team has teed up this video
I want to get your reaction okay you
ready let's do this
for Lego Enthusiast Lucas Letcher these
aren't just toys this is the Lego
Creator Palace Cinema they're serious
money makers that he buys and sells for
profit the biggest online database of
collectible Lego sets lists 1.2 billion
dollars worth of the toys around the
world see the Lego Tron up here we're in
the three to four hundred dollar range
this Lego Tie Fighter 200 a piece is
what these are selling the returns that
I typically will see is somewhere
between 150 to 250 percent on a Lego set
researchers say electric is one of tens
of thousands who concerned by the recent
volatility of stocks and bonds are
betting on the reliable returns from
this tiny but growing Market
wow dude move over crypto yeah Back That
Thing Up Beanie Babies wow we have a new
toy in town okay so this brings me to an
article John here's the headline for you
adults are buying toys for themselves
and it's the biggest source of growth
for the industry and there's a new name
for these people they are called cadults
they have a great fondness for cartoons
superheroes Star Wars Lego and in recent
years toy makers like Mattel have
created Lines Just for these consumers
because they're stupid that's why well
think about it they have the Nostalgia
and they have the buying power they've
got money now right you know how many
times I've tried to convince my wife
that this new guitar or hunting is an
investment yeah no my truck is an
investment it's uh it's gonna depreciate
and then suddenly re-appreciate it yeah
you know who can't afford this kids and
so uh I mean it's astronomically
expensive these days but there's some
fascinating stuff in here uh in the
article and there's one that's connected
to it that's interesting investing in
Lego more lucrative than gold a study
suggestion okay I hate these oh gosh
you're giving me hemorrhoids I hate
these
brick of Lego the worst the worst the
worst the worst
so I'm a hundred percent for buying toys
if you got it buy whatever dude if you
got the money have a great time you've
got your weird Hobbies I've got
down with the Legos I love them I dude I
can sit there and do Legos all day it's
quiet we put on some music it's awesome
I love Legos I love them I love them
to lie to yourself and others about them
being a investment property
dude
if it all goes down
we'll be trading in Legos right and
someone comes to my house and they're
like hey I've got a tin of coffee and
some cigarettes can I have a Starfighter
Lego set it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen it's it's trading more
lucrative than gold because we have more
money than since and there's more
circulating dollars which means there's
more of things we can buy and there's
people right now on Etsy or eBay or
whatever going that guy's full of crap
what an idiot whatever you're cool
keep buying and selling
toys knock your lights out rock onto the
break it on dude
you're gonna be sitting I I dude I'm
just sitting with people who've got a
lot of guitars they got a lot of guns
they've got a lot of whatever this is my
investment bro sell some
they're getting way less than they
thought on on average or it's it's all
it's just imaginary dude it's just like
we all have those Beanie Babies In The
Attic where we were going oh I could
have sold those at one point I don't
have a beanie baby I know you have a
huge collection I sold mine okay I don't
know I don't know where they went John
but yes we all have things they're like
no it's worth uh this much bro but it's
pretty I mean it's a fascinating stat if
you just look at it oh it is it is it is
the market for secondhand Lego rises in
value by 11 annually which is faster and
better than the rate of return than gold
stocks Bond stamps and wine in the last
decade or two when there's been the
single highest wealth accumulation in
the history of planet earth mostly
over this we can get that's a whole
other conversation so yes
congratulations yeah I think it's
collecting guys I'd rather you uh invest
in Lego than stamps so I you know
there's some good things there but I
will say the company Lego or they are
genius marketers and here's how they did
this John uh they use limited production
runs they use collector special editions
huge and scarcity on the second hand
Market that is what has kept these
prices up it's simply supply and demand
and they are so good at creating the
scarcity the urgency you'll never get
this collector set again everything's a
collector set now it's like blood Legos
right that's how it goes it's
unbelievable so uh great lesson in
marketing terrible investment I'd rather
you be investing in your retirement and
if you want to just enjoy Legos and it's
a collector thing for you
a bunch of them you've already maxed out
retirement you don't have any debt
you're using your fun money that's great
we are happy for you we're not mad at
those adults out there
but please do not delay your retirement
because you're like oh but honey if I
get this Lego set it's going to be worth
way more than my retirement account or
here's here's like let's here's me being
like just honest
man if you if you buy Legos and collect
Legos and they go up in value and you're
buying great and I can't I didn't I
can't argue with the data the last
decade man these things have done great
awesome they're going up in value so
you're you're an adult you're a
collector you're going to buy some
expensive Lego sets that are rare
awesome
what I don't like about these kind of
studies that get dropped out with
headlines like this is that
people who watch too much YouTube
then go I'm missing the boat here and
they start buying Lego sets with credit
cards they start buying quote-unquote
great deals with fill in the blank ways
of borrowing money
with the idea that I'm this is gonna
return me 11 I could sell this for 400 I
only bought it for 50 and I bought on a
credit card and that's the that's the
folks who get in trouble if you buy
these things with cash and you end up
with a huge pile of Legos in the
apocalypse is no harm no foul it's fine
right
but dude if you have a pile of debt
buying these things with the hope you're
going to pay off you're just going to
get in a long line of crypto folks and
along with Beanie Baby folks in the long
line of tulip folks and and on and on
and on right
yeah we we don't know the future of Lego
I mean one thing could take they could
have a tweet that takes them down and
the stuff I'll keep rocking with Legos
dude I'm all about it but but it's it's
very very risky and we see this across
all other Industries John sneakers or
there's a lot of sneaker heads out there
and they're buying the collector's shoe
and there's a lot of urgency and
scarcity and so whenever there's a lot
of urgency and scarcity I like to just
pause and go why am I actually why do I
have this fomo yeah and I go oh it's
marketing got it I don't actually need
it it's not actually a great investment
I actually don't know anything about it
and so unless you're a super Lego fan
who just knows the ins and outs and
knows exactly what set is what value on
eBay don't get involved in the stuff for
the investment Do It For the Love of
Lego yeah because you want it the for
the love love of Lego you have a t-shirt
that says that man that's super pretty
cool all right so let's go to Shannon do
we have time to take a call what do you
think awesome boy it's risky pretty
close it is so risky we got a minute
John I don't know I don't want to show
shortchange them all right let's go
let's go here let's uh Building Wealth
in this economy we keep hearing that
question uh we keep hearing that
question and we get your confusion
there's tons of noise out there right
now about inflation massive layoffs
investing in Legos not in Lego the
company but just buying a bunch of boxes
of toys Rising interest rates you
deserve answers that's why we're coming
to a city near you with our Building
Wealth live event they were sold out all
across the country last year we had gosh
how many do we have the other night 100
150 000 easily it was wild yeah
um Dave Ramsey and our team of
personalities will be doing a Building
Wealth live spring tour we'll dig into
Hot Topics give you a proven plan to
build wealth and keep it yes even in
this madness each building live event
will have its own Flair and unique
lineup Dave Dave George Campbell Rachel
Cruz and Jade warshaw will be in
Indianapolis on February 16th Dave can
Coleman me and Jade will be in Austin on
February 23rd we're heading to Salt Lake
City on April 24th where you can catch
Dave Rachel George and Christina and our
last stop Dave kin me and Christina will
be wrapping up the Building Wealth live
tour in Anaheim California on May 2nd
take a start at 49 bucks you can get a
four pack of tickets for 175 bucks bring
your friends it's a blast and it's a lot
of fun go to ramsesolutions.com
events to reserve your seats I noticed
they didn't pair us up John were too
dangerous of a calm when we come
together it's off the rails a little bit
but join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
got to Shannon in Dallas Texas Shannon
what's up
[Music]
hi
um so my dad recently died and my
husband and I are going to be moving
into their house with my mom which means
we need to buy a build a mother-in-law
Edition so we were just trying to figure
out the best way to do that financially
for all three of us okay let's back all
the way up when's your dad pass away
oh my gosh so this is like right away
yeah in two weeks I'm sorry what
happened Shannon
uh pulmonary fibrosis idiopathic
pulmonary fibrosis so right away right
away
yeah
man I'm so sorry I'm sorry
so what what's causing this sudden
like we have to move is it for Mom is it
what's the reason behind it
yeah she's lonely she knows she'll be
lonely she's never lived on her own
before and the house is old it was built
in the 60s so she wants help for and
it's on a lot of acreage so she just
wants help from my husband and I to live
in the house
so a very
I'll just tell you right out of the gate
the um
wisdom I received from the man who
trained me Dr Andy young the guy who
trained me on crisis situations in
response was one of my psychology
professors
and then he also served as like a
personal he helped me out there's some
pretty messy stuff
the rule was always after a major shift
a major tragedy do nothing for six
months to a year
because everybody starts scrambling
and people who are on the periphery here
like you guys are you're watching your
mom you miss your dad it's so sudden
Everything feels like like you know
what's up is down and what's down is up
and the impulse that we have we only
have we have a fight or flight right
it's just start swinging at things or to
start running and the impulse is to go
do a thing because that's that's our
impulse
and we will people will take out
mortgages they'll move across the
country they'll quit their job they'll
move in they'll move somebody in and
then ever the Smoke Clears the pain is
still there
the hurt is still there the loss is
still there but the Smoke Clears and
everyone goes oh gosh what do we do
and now you got another mess on top of a
mess
my greatest recommendation would be
find a way to to have a uh in between
for the next three to six to nine months
and that might mean mom's just going to
move in it's going to be real tight for
all of us where we have to figure it out
or we're gonna get a camper and move it
in the driveway or something but
selling your house moving it doing a big
old Renault all that stuff and you don't
know she made the smoke may clear in six
months and a couple of her friends say
hey why don't you move over to this
community and get a condo and do this
and so who knows what that's gonna land
the hardest thing to do right now is to
sit in grief
you hear what I'm saying like it's hard
just to be still for a minute and say
man I miss dad
okay I appreciate that how does that
sound it's so safe yeah to say six
months from now
she and you're awesome you're like okay
that's cute all right so we're gonna
build this house here's what it's gonna
be all right so tell me you're thinking
about selling your house and moving in
like tell me what you're thinking about
doing
but we want to build her a mother-in-law
Edition in her own house
uh well it's kind of it'll be like
connected off to the side of her house
so that we still have separate spaces
but she can come visit whenever she
wants to so she's going to move out of
her house
and she's gonna move out of her master
bedroom and her kitchen and her whole
world and she's gonna move into a
mother-in-law Suite right next door or
sort of attached
yeah so for her this is very exciting
that it gives her something to look
forward to so that she doesn't just sit
and wallow in her grief there's a lot of
ways you could occupy yourself without
doing all of this she could find Hobbies
so the question is this is a lot of work
and a lot of money do you guys have the
money to cash flow this today
my husband and I are sitting on a lot of
a lot of so once we sell this house we
will have money to do all of that plus
my mom has a very comfortable retirement
so what what's her hashtag look like
about a million
okay how old is she
61. okay do you have brothers and
sisters
uh I have two sisters it's been a very
open conversation with the sisters we're
all on the same page okay what I would
hate for you to do if you just you're
just bent on doing this we gotta do this
the next two months we gotta get it
going gotta get it going gotta get it
going do you have to do this
you sell your house
I want you to buy her house from her
okay otherwise the whole thing gets very
messy because technically y'all are
homeless
right so we that had been what we were
initially talking about but then we
started planning a few worst case
scenario issues making sure we have a
solution for those so worst case
scenario my husband and I hate each
other in five years and we're getting a
divorce how do we make sure that my
divorce doesn't make my mom homeless it
will that should be it will so should we
put my mom's name on the house like or
is that a bad idea nope
number one just don't get divorced in
five years you'll work on your marriage
that's the plan I'm more concerned with
a more realistic probability is
um
your mom
passes away in two years
and your sisters come and say well we
want our peace
that's what happens more often in our
world or your your mother's cousin says
hey she promised me X and she sues you
for that house and it's in your mom's
name and actually your mom just had a
will and left everything to all the kids
and it's then now we've got a mess and
you spent 30 grand on the in-law suite
but you don't own the home right and you
cashed out your equity in your home to
buy this attached to pay for an
attachment to the see what I'm saying
this because it's super messy
and so the cleanest way is to I'll buy
mom's house from you even if you sit
down with your sisters and say that
means that I'll take less of splitting
up the nest egg when Mom passes away
however you need to redo the well will
even if you need to sit down with an
attorney get it all clear here's what
we're looking for super super clear
boundaries
because if you own this house and let's
say you all get divorced either your
husband leaves and he takes a buy out
right and we'll figure out how to get
the bot pay the buyout down the road or
you and your mom leave and he buys you
out and you all move in together
somewhere else like that that doesn't
bother me nearly as much as she passes
away y'all don't really own this house
it was just kind of a handshake
agreement between sisters and one of
your sisters doesn't like you anymore or
one of your sister's husbands gets them
gets in some gambling debt and they need
the money like who knows how this thing
plays out and I know you're thinking
that not in our family but George and I
wouldn't have a job if that didn't
happen in a lot of families okay so it's
just just a Clarity Clarity Clarity
Clarity clarity
so would the plan be you guys move into
this house until mom passes and then
we'll figure something out if we want to
stay there
by the house and then my mom uses what
Equity she's going to get because she
has visiting a lot of equity in that
house she's going to use that money to
build the Mother-in-law house okay
okay but then long term do you guys want
to live there
yes this we plan on staying there so
you're good with the next 20 years
living at that on the property there
yes absolutely okay I do want you all to
have the conversation because this will
be very hard I'm just I'm just thinking
about myself
if all of a sudden my kids were in my
kitchen
and sleeping in my room and I was having
to go outside to go to my little
apartment that whole I would feel weird
for me
and I would wreck a possibility of
possibly selling this whole property and
you'll buy another place that already
has a mother-in-law Suite in it part of
the healing Journey or do you live next
door right she might wake up in six
months and be like I need to get out of
his house because everything reminds me
of my husband that's why we say to wait
and slow down I'd hate for you to do
this and her be like I can't be in this
house anymore now we got another problem
now we all got to move again
um but if you're bent on it make sure
everything is outlined and clear you've
talked about hey this is going to be our
kitchen it's gonna be our bedroom it's
gonna be our kid you kids rooms
um have that hot it's gonna be a messy
messy conversation
um or consider buying a completely
separate house selling this thing
um grieving the loss of this the passing
of this the the dream you had is gonna
be a different dream now and then start
building something new moving forward
but at the end of the day she's really
blessed to have you in her quarter she's
a lucky lucky woman to have you sorry
about your Dad sorry about your dad
we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
scripture of the day is Proverbs 31 8-9
speak up for those who cannot speak for
themselves for the rights of all who are
destitute speak up and judge fairly
defend the rights of the poor and the
needy
Jordan Peterson says when you have
something to say silence is a lie
I like that all right let's go to
Stephen in Springfield what's up Stephen
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
got it what's up dude
oh so I got a question on um kind of how
to handle I ended up taking on Saturdays
at work
um so I'm bringing home about an extra
350 a week
um I got about twenty six thousand
dollars in
um Consumer Debt uh through different
loans and everything like that uh with
different interest rates so I'm just
trying to figure out every time I seem
to have extra money I throw it across
the board and I'm trying to figure out
if it's better to just say pick one pay
it off then roll it or what is your guys
input on something like that so what
kind of debts are these if you listed
out the 26
so I've got a car
um credit card
um between me and my wife and then
um I have a Peloton spin bike that has a
zero percent so I kind of always throw
that one on the back burner and try to
go after the car that has a 5.4 percent
and the credit card that has a 14
um but then again every time I put a
thousand dollars on the credit card
something comes up and it feels like
that thousands back on there can we can
we agree before George walks you through
it that the way you're doing is not
working
correct absolutely yes dude you're
you've already won you've already won
congratulations all right uh as a as a
fellow math nerd on paper you're like
well I should pay off the highest
interest at first that makes sense
mathematically I'll pay the least amount
of interest but what we found is that
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's
only 20 nerdy head knowledge and so the
way we've seen it where people actually
get this debt out of their life once and
for all is using the debt snowball
method which is ignoring the interest
rate just cross it out you don't know
the interest rates anymore all you see
is individual balances we're going to
pay minimum payments on all of the
balances except for that smallest one
and with all that side work all of the
extra money your cutting expenses
selling stuff you're gonna throw that
the smallest debt it's going to free up
a payment you're going to roll it to the
next one and the next one and man that
is the fastest way now is it
mathematically the best way no you
probably could save a few dollars on
interest but you'll also probably hang
on to that debt for longer because it's
hard to make progress
yeah and that's exactly where I feel
like I'm at right now and that's totally
been listening to you guys more and more
and just been trying to tackle it and I
figured here we are and let's try to see
what you guys input on it is there's
something I mean there's something
powerful Stephen about this you have a
debt with 500 you have a debt with 300
you have a loan to a buddy for 1500
bucks you got a credit card five
thousand dollars and you get a thousand
bucks and you throw it at that car
and it goes down to four thousand
you still all owe all the same people
money
correct
there's something else if you owed six
people money and you took that thousand
bucks and you paid off that 300 one in
that 500 one you just cut two sharks out
of your life
there's something powerful
psychologically
like I'm actually making progress when
you just knock five thousand to four
thousand it that's a lot of money but it
doesn't feel that like it because you're
still paying the same people there's
something about knocking these things
out smallest to largest that you start
to believe I can do this and then I like
it this is me personally I like that
credit card just hanging out there just
gnawing at you 14 like it just gives you
it gives you hemorrhoids there's no
Preparation H in sight you're just gonna
you gotta deal with it it makes you I
gotta get that thing out of my life but
the only way I get it is to get these
other three out and so I'm just gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna power through does
that make sense
absolutely yeah because I'm gearing up
for tax returns and stuff like that and
my issue at hand was all right well how
am I going to use that money
um if I do get any or I always try to
break even but you know some years you
end up getting something back and I'm
just hoping that if I do I wanted to use
it in the right way instead of year
after year feeling like I'm just putting
a thousand dollars across the board and
like you guys are saying I still have
three other debts that just have a
little bit lower of a balance yeah dude
you know what to do man commit to this
debt snowball and you're going to be
debt free in no time
very cool I appreciate that you got it
brother hey holler at us when you uh get
all these paid off man and we'll
celebrate with you let's go to Parker in
San Antonio Texas what's up Parker
hey guys how are you doing excellent
brother what's up
a bit of a predicament I'm in
um about a long commute for my wife so
uh we are recently married in September
and she moved in
um in in San Antonio and so I get a job
I kind of work all over the San Antonio
area in the hospitals but she got a job
in Fredericksburg which is about an hour
away yep wine country man beautiful area
yes yes it is uh very beautiful out
there but
um right now you know we're making some
good money but all of her paycheck seems
to be going towards her gas bill
um you know she drives a truck up to
Fredericksburg every day and back and
forward and back so it's two hours at
minimum a day
um so we've got a lease that's ending up
in May we're renting right now and we're
looking pretty heavily to to go ahead
and you know buy a house uh caveat being
is the closer you get to Fredericksburg
and that beautiful wine country the more
expensive things get that's right
um I will tell you there is some
research that is has some correlation
between length of commute and all sorts
of
physical and psychological challenges
your body knows that you're driving 75
miles an hour in a metal missile down
the road and that you are relying on
everybody else on the road to not do
something dumb so you don't all end up
in a huge like your body knows as much
as we just hop in the car and go and it
wears you out and wears you out and it
wears you out and it wears you out
um my personal rule is 30 minutes and uh
that's that's pushing it I think when I
just look at the overall psychological
well-being of being in my relational
well-being with my family and my friends
I just I my time is so precious
especially you throw kids in the mix
time is so precious it's the only thing
on earth we can't get back and to spend
an hour two hours in the car every day
instead of it face to face with our
loved ones or connecting with other
people or work whatever the thing is man
that's a that's a sacrifice that I think
long term just doesn't add up
um I I I would love to see y'all rent
and until you can afford to buy a place
man
how close are you guys to being able to
afford that are you guys debt free with
the emergency fund
so uh my wife has got about 15 000 left
on her truck uh she's been making good
progress on that should be able to pay
it off sometime uh in the next two years
but together we've got about
um 80 000 saved up we're recently
married so we haven't quite combined
finances and stuff like that but we've
got about 80 000 saved up thinking about
putting either 50 or 60 down for a down
payment
okay well we've got priorities here
which is we're paying off the debt is 15
total all the debt you guys have
uh yes that's it we head off today
no no student loans before the day is
over pay the truck off this is not her
truck to pay off this is y'all so you're
married everything's everything's won
pay the truck off and then you guys need
a fully funded emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses would you call
that fifteen twenty thousand
yeah okay 15 on the car 15 for the
emergency fund that leaves you with 50
now towards a down payment
and so now we go what's the goal for the
down payment how quickly can we save up
and able to to be able to afford a house
near her work and if that means we need
to save up for another year we're gonna
go rent for a year great and I think
that'd be I think that'd be wise for you
all to move closer to Fredericksburg
area rent and find out exactly where you
want to live Vibe it out or get to meet
some real estate agents and find a great
deal that will come up in the next year
and it might mean getting a condo or a
town home even though you really wanted
the single family home closer to the
it's going to have to take some
compromise but it's worth it can I
challenge you on something Parker
yeah what's up you're newly married
you got to be fully All In
you got to put all your money in the
same checking account you got to share
Visions you got to share goals you got
to share finances her debt is your debt
her truck is your truck there's no more
of this you pay that off and I'm gonna
pay this bill and her gas bill it's
y'all's gas bill you got to start living
like that planning like that and create
a life together not these two
independent lives and live like
roommates that just make out okay let's
let's go all in on this marriage let's
do it together you got this as the
Ramsey show another show in the books
we'll see you soon right here live from
Nashville on the Ramsey Show
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]